regardez regardez la photo oh non et si
en effet la statue bronze est rigée à
Funchal la capitale est très bien garni
au niveau du short et ses fans se
prennent en photo en frottant son entre
jambes ce qu'il la police et l'a rendu
plus brillant à cet endroit leur salaire
peut parfois atteindre des sommes
astronomiques autour de 35000 euros par
mois tout est influenceur c'est Nabilla
et son mari Thomas Vergara qui
décrocherait la première place avec plus
de 350 000 euros par mois non ça va très
bien je suis très heureuse
sont nettement plus importantes 41
millions d'euros par an pour Messi 40
millions par an pour Neymar et bientôt
100 millions par an pour Kylian Mbappe
sans compter les sponsors c'est
symbolique
c'est agréable de lire et de voir que
que des maisons existent et qu'elles
sont elles sont faites pour nous ces
maisons là mais c'est vrai que quand on
descend un peu plus bas qui a le prix
c'est fini là c'est des illusion totale
c'est hors de prix enfin pour les
animateurs les salaires varient beaucoup
tout dépend de l'audience de l'émission
et de la chaîne de diffusion pour
exemple Jean-Pierre Foucault prendrait
35000 euros pour une émission Miss
France exceptionnelle
27000 euros par émission The Voice il
faut que je travaille quand même un
appartement pour acheter impossible il
faut que tu travailles pendant 20
minutes pendant 50 ans voilà et encore
il faut deux vies
[Rires]
j'espère que vous passez une bonne
matinée on est ravi de vous aider et
vous l'avez compris il arrivera un
moment donné où il faudra quand même
qu'on prenne un suppo et qu'on aille
vite au lit mais
c'est loin d'être terminé tout ça vous
l'avez bien compris aussi
3632 c'est au téléphone 7 21 par SMS 50
000 francs
celle-là alors papi
Clara Luciani est plus à l'aise au micro
que devant un appareil photo la
chanteuse a récemment refusé un selfie à
une fan qui l'a alors insulté sur les
réseaux réponse de l'artiste il y a deux
haines faites un effort 3 même si on
compte votre haine Clara Luciani a
ensuite posté un long texte sur
Instagram pour s'expliquer elle évoque
sa timidité un rapport contrarié avec
son image et rappelle qu'elle est
chanteuse et non mannequin pour
l'exercice de base évidemment c'est de
les plier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment on ouvre une porte depuis des
millénaires
on tire et on pousse d'accord c'est
comme ça que ça se passe on s'est dit
que c'est un peu démodé enfin c'est
plutôt un designer autrichien qui a
décidé que c'était un peu démodé et qui
a tout simplement imagé une porte où là
on va ni tirer ni pousser on va en fait
enlever les carrés qu'on va voir sur les
images vous le voyez très bien ici et
tout simplement en fait cette porte elle
va elle va permettre de soit se rouler
soit se dérouler et de se remettre
dessus c'est ni pratique ni spécialement
confort voilà c'est juste très design
une râpe pourrait éplucher des oignons
vous êtes sûr
[Musique]
ça déchire et ça marche pas j'ai peur de
me couper les mains
[Musique]
attention roulement de tambour le
projectile est en place trois dehors
il reste bloqué poussez Bernard
regardez regardez la moto bloquée par
les spectateurs et les trois coureurs
qui étaient derrière sont tombés
Christopher Froome alors maillot jaune
arrêté en pleine ascension du Mont
Ventoux son vélo est cassé mais pas
question d'abandonner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'a jamais vu ça il n'a plus de vélo
aussi très déculpabilisé de l'Amérique à
se dire en une grande puissance et on y
va pleinement et on fait pas bien faire
les Américains
ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas vu ça
[Musique]
patate douce
avec la pomme de terre bah j'ai vu que
tu avais bien aimé quand tu l'as goûté
[Musique]